- Hello, my name is Jason Schwartzman.
- I'm Adam Stockhausen.
- And this is "Trade Secrets."
(bright upbeat music)
You create the entire environment.
It was totally built.
It's a rare thing to be, like,
in a set that was completely built
with functioning water,
electricity, bathroom,
built in a place where
that didn't exist before.
- Right.
- Can I just ask very
quickly, what was it before?
Did you have to go and
scope out the area with Wes
to see physically if the
landscape could handle it?
- Well, normally, yeah.
Like, normally we would, you know?
Normally we would go physically there
and stomp around the place
and look at it from 100 different angles
and try to figure all of that out.
But we were prepping this
and having those conversations
in, like, the early mid-summer of 2020,
and it wasn't possible.
So it became a totally virtual process,
and we were just shooting
emails back and forth,
and kind of studying, like,
all the different ways
we could go about this and, you know,
should it be more of a
location-based thing,
or should it be a totally built set
in a back lot but at a
studio somewhere, you know?
And so that that kind
conversation kind of was drifted
more and more and more
towards building it,
but building it at a site
rather than at a studio, you know,
and finding just the right place for it.
- Was that something that you were excited
to land on as a choice?
- Oh yeah, yeah. That was great.
It's great, you know,
and then comes all the
realities of it, right?
It got really complicated
because it's in Europe,
and so it's not just
sort of one simple field
that you have to deal with,
but it's been subdivided
over the centuries.
And so I think that,
like, the plot of land
where Asteroid City sat
was 137 different fields,
like, some of them, tiny, tiny tiny.
And so the production locations team
and Jeremy Dawson were digging
and digging and digging
and trying to get, you know,
all these people to be on board
with this completely strange thing
that we were asking them to do
instead of growing
watermelons that year, so...
(both laugh)
- Like, building an outdoor set
that has to not only be filmable
and have lights and electricity,
but has to be left outside.
- It had this element of,
like, civil engineering to it
that is sort of unusual,
where before we dealt with
any of the scenery going in,
we wired the place and we did drainage,
but we laid septic lines so
that we could have bathrooms
so that again, the whole
thing is functional
and the whole thing you
could just plug the lights
in to the light sockets,
and they would work.
They would turn on.
You know, you didn't have to, like,
run cables from everywhere.
And it does take some time to do it,
but it's really enjoyable to do it too,
because one of the things
about doing it this way
that we're talking about with Wes,
is it's kind of not the normal way, right?
It's not the sort of normal,
"Okay, I'll be in the trailer,"
kind of way of doing it.
And so a lot of it does involve
being the communicator of that,
and being like, "No, no
we're gonna do this thing
a totally different way,
and it's super exciting.
And get on board, let's go. Let's do it."
- [Jason] Yeah, right.
- You know?
But it always does seem
like there's a curve
through the process of making the film
where at the beginning
there's a lot of, like,
all right I know it seems crazy, but-
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You know, we're gonna do it this way.
Trust me. You know?
- I'm curious to know
what it looks like now.
- Oh, I have photos.
It looks exactly like
before we arrived. Yeah.
- That's amazing.
- And because it was a
part of the agreement
with the farmers to respect their work
and what they were doing to say,
"No, it's really important
to us to get this back to you
in exactly the condition
which you gave it to us."
So, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- How is it different from imagining it,
building it, to getting
it in front of the camera
making all of it real,
movable, functional,
to really begin that process?
- One thing that was really
interesting on this one
was because the place is gigantic,
but it's not as gigantic as a real valley
in the, you know, in the desert, right?
It's still using all the
forced perspective tricks
and techniques that you would
if you were on a sound stage.
Just on a bigger scale, right?
And for me, I mean,
maybe because, you know,
it's the not the 1930s and
we don't do this every day.
Those tricks and
techniques are a little bit
like trying to re-figure out this older,
interesting way of doing things.
And it comes with this, like,
"I hope I got it right."
The challenging part was,
like, where should it be?
Should it, you know, can it be here?
Does it have to be here?
And also, if something
isn't four miles away
sitting on the horizon
line, it's actually closer.
Where's that, like, magical point
where your brain isn't gonna believe
that it's really far away?
And we definitely hit some snags
where a couple of our things, like,
we took pictures and it was like,
"It doesn't look far enough away."
And so we had to make
an artificial horizon.
- Oh, right, right.
- And so we made this kinda, like,
I don't know if you remember
from driving around,
there was that little thing.
And we made a absolutely
gigantic kind of perimeter-
- Crater.
That the whole set is sitting inside of.
But it gave us a new horizon,
and it made all of our things work.
And that was totally trial
and error. I had no idea.
But when push came to shove,
it became do everything.
I mean, I think a lot of
it comes from theater,
and I think a lot of it, for me,
comes from, you know,
and I have a background
in making sets on stage.
And so that it's kind of second nature,
that part of it to me.
But then there's this other part of it
where Wes and I are grabbing
frames from old films,
from "The Wizard of Oz,"
and I'm drawing red
lines on it and saying,
"I think, you know,
this is the foreground.
This is a middle ground piece
that's partly in miniature.
And then here's the background
that I think is really in miniature."
You know, and we're sending
things back and forth like that
trying to kind of, like,
forensically figure it out.
And with Wes, there are layers
of how he got the idea for the thing,
and it's very specific.
- But I mean, after working
with him now, repeatedly,
do you know to ask those questions
or you know that's part of the...
Like, there is that forensic archeology
that's happening with...
You know to do that with him.
That's-
- Yeah, for sure. For sure.
And the forensic archeology
is kind of a great way
to describe the entire process,
because, like, for this one,
it isn't kind of an open-ended sort of,
well, what is Asteroid City?
I mean, we're talking about
the big picture question,
of course, of, like, it's not
really a place on the map.
It's a set of a town meant to be that way,
meant to feel that way.
But then from the very beginning,
he's already having shot ideas.
He's already story boarding.
He's already working out his
animatic version of the film.
And so it is kind of a forensic process.
This one was an especially
complicated puzzle,
because the sets weren't
independent things
that we could go to and then leave behind.
The sets all kind of work
together, like a giant puzzle.
- Well, that's the other
thing too, is, like,
when Wes asks you a question,
"Adam, can we try this? Can we do that?"
And I would watch you
come in, and you'd look,
and you guys would have
a discussion about it.
How are you economic with your energies
giving the person what's
needed in the moment
versus what's needed in the long term?
- Right, I mean, that's, that's-
- That's what we're talking about.
- That's the every day,
all day. That's it.
- That's the trade secret.
- That's it.
- Don't say it.
- Yeah.
Well, it's a total balancing act every day
to try to manage exactly that.
Like, how can you do
the most that you can do
to service the last minute request
or the problem of right now,
without hurting or endangering
the next thing, right?
And so you just do your
best to balance it.
And I do my best to, like,
try to just be super clear
with Wes and say, "This is where I'm at."
Can I ask you one?
- Sure.
- I just...
Because we were talking about the sort
of technical forensics
nature of figuring out
these complicated shots,
but they do become very complex.
And how is it for you when,
I assume having, trying to
have your process in quiet.
Meanwhile there's this incredibly complex
technical set of requirements
and marks to hit.
And then I'm doing stuff all around you
with moving things and adjusting things,
and I'm always fascinated watching you
and kind of feeling bad, frankly,
that I have got so much of a circus
going on around you, you know?
- We need the circus.
- How is that for you?
- Well, it's different in
every situation, I think.
But like, for me, that's what I love
about what we get to do.
I like everyone helping each other
to do something for someone else.
It's my dream.
It's why I, like, it's why I like music.
I think it's 'cause it is being...
I like a band. I mean, I like a group.
And it's, like, to me it's essential.
I love that. We're all part of the take.
There's a scene in the movie
where I have a lighter,
and I, right in the
beginning and I turn around,
and it's filled up with gasoline.
And I turn around, I light it.
There's very many different
things have to occur.
And to do it, it was...
The gasoline had to be the
right amount of pressure
of liquid coming out.
The spout had to be in the right spot.
The lighter, if it's too wet, can't light.
- [Adam] It's not gonna go, yeah.
- So many things have to go right.
I remember when we got a take
that we were like, "That's the feeling."
Everyone was hugging and
high fiving and stuff.
And I just think that's, like,
that's the ultimate feeling,
'cause it's not, like,
it's not about one person.
You know what I mean?
It's like-
- Totally, yeah, yeah.
- Everybody, I love that we're
all there for each other.
I thrive on that and I love it.
And also, just I've never gotten to be
around something like this.
For me it was, like, this
crazy dream come true
that I never knew I was having.
Like, you know what I mean?
Like, to walk down a road,
like, a forced perspective road
you're not supposed to really be able
to walk down it, I guess.
- Right, right.
- 'Cause it's meant to just-
- But it was big enough in full scale.
- But it was real. Exactly.
Like, it's bizarre.
Like, it looked painted,
but you could drive
down it in a golf cart.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And it would get...
You're very rarely in
the forced perspective.
And I remember one of
the last days, Wes and I,
we had this really wonderful day
where we kind of went and
said goodbye to the place.
And we walked down to the end of the road.
Wes put his arm up on one of
the, like, telephone poles.
I was kind of looking around
and I was like, "That's amazing."
I don't have much forced
perspective in my life,
my daily life.
- [Adam] Your daily life.
- (laughs) Yeah. So I wish I did.
But so for me, it was, like,
kind of this, like, I
couldn't get enough of it.
Well, I'm just thinking about the scenes
that Scarlett and I did together.
You know, some of the, like,
I remember just one day,
because of the nature of the space
that was, like, a little curtain,
like, a little instead of
a wall in this one spot,
that was the only kind of way
that I could get into this thing.
That gives the scene
a whole other dynamic.
Like, the way things are constructed
helped the actors so much.
That's what I love.
I just love how the space
informs every decision that's made.
- I love that that's exciting.
- But I know. It's the best.
- Oh, oh, it's amazing.
'Cause I honestly, I'm always like,
I'm sorry to tell you, you're
gonna have to turn sideways,
and then this, and then
there's a snake pit
you have to jump over.
And then I feel, like,
I'm always throwing these terrible
difficulties in front of you.
- The coolest thing is this
movie has got so many actors
with so much experience
and such incredible people.
All of them, basically the
way they looked at the alien
was the way they all
looked at Asteroid City
for the first time when they got there.
It's incredible, the sense of wonder
when something's really
beautifully crafted
and cared for and so special.
Like, you just don't experience it.
It doesn't matter who you are.
It's the look in the face is the same.
I mean, I saw every,
'cause I was there from
the beginning to the end.
I saw all these actors go.
"Wesley, let's take 'em over there."
And it's just a testament
to you that Tom Hanks
has been on a lot of sets, you know,
and, like, he's just like,
"This is the most incredible
place I've ever been."
- I mean, that's so, so very kind.
- Truly, just, like, the wonder
and the joy and every person,
like, really, it's so unusual.
- There was something about it.
There was something about that place
that was really extraordinary.
And I've been really
trying to think of, like,
what it was.
And because, in a way, it was very simple.
- Yeah.
- You know, in a way,
there was a gas station
and there was a little lunch net
and there was a small motel.
But I kind of feel like
that sense of wonder
that you get of Wes' vision of the world
when you see the finished film,
we all got to experience that
in a very complete way of his vision
of what Asteroid City
was to him was expressed.
You know, we were able
to build the whole thing.
- Exactly.
- At one time, you know?
We were able to sort of lay it out,
and see the whole thing.
And so in a funny way, I
think we got to experience
what the audience gets to experience
at the end of the process.
We got to live it while we were there,
which was super, super, super fun.
- Well, Adam, thank you for your time.
We should...
I don't want to give away
too many more trade secrets.
Thank you for sharing your
information and curiosity.
- Thank you so much.
This was really great.
- It's the best, the best.
(bright gentle music)